hi everyone welcome in this video we are
going to learn about git and github why
they are important and also how to use
them so we're going to start off going
over the terms and concepts that you
will use in git and the ecosystem and
then get into practical applications
this tutorial will include everything
from basic git repositories to what is
github - some more intermediate concepts
like branching and merging and forking
and that kind of stuff I want to quickly
introduce myself my name is Gwen
and I run a YouTube channel called
Faraday Academy where I upload coding
tutorial videos and I also do a couple
live streams a week mostly on Python and
JavaScript topics as well as some more
general purpose coding videos you can
also find me on Twitter and Instagram
and pretty much everywhere by typing in
Gwen Faraday and let's get started with
the tutorial
I want to start off here by defining
what get is get is what we call a
version control system that is free and
open source and it's the most widely
used version control system in
development today most programmers
interact with git on a daily basis so
what is version control version control
is basically a way that we as
programmers track our code changes we
basically save an initial version of our
code into git and then when we update
code we can save it into get again and
again and again and again and throughout
time as our code continues to change we
can look back at all of the changes we
have made over time this helps us to see
and understand what we did when as well
as track down bugs or go back to a
previous version of the code if we need
to so let's look at some of the terms
that you're going to see in this video
first of all I use the term directory
which is also known as a folder on your
computer when I reference the terminal
or command line I basically mean an
application that runs on your computer
which is just an interface where you can
type in text commands you can navigate
around files and folders create files
change update things install and run
programs and much more you might also
hear me use the term CLI which is just
the command line interface many programs
that you install as a programmer will
require you to interact with them via
text commands in the command line so you
will be typing out some text and hitting
Enter instead of say double clicking on
a folder icon on your desktop just think
of it as another way to run a program
now you might be wondering why are we
going to use the terminal or command
line instead of using one of these
beautiful applications that handle
interacting with git for us well as
programmer
it's always good to use the terminal so
you learn the git commands and workflow
of git as well as become accustomed to
it as a developer you are going to be
using the terminal a lot to install see
allies run programs search for things
etc throughout your development career
and learning git is a great way to get
started with the command line CD stands
for change directory it's basically the
same thing as when you double-click on a
folder using the icons on your desktop
well in the command line if you want to
move into a folder or even up to a
parent folder you'll use CD followed by
the directions to get to whatever folder
on your system you want to get to a code
editor of course is a place to write
code you'll probably see this in a lot
of different programming videos but just
in case you are unfamiliar with it you
can write code anywhere in a tux
document word processor anything but
there are special ones that are designed
with lots of tools and features for
programmers and these are called code
editors now some people get confused by
the word repository because it has
multiple meanings but in the world of
programming it usually refers to a git
repository which is basically just your
project or the folder place where your
project is kept you can call it a
repository people also sometimes confuse
git and github now git is the tool that
tracks the changes in your code over
time github is a website where you host
all of your git repositories being
online it makes it easy to work in
groups with other people and organize
your projects into a portfolio for you
to show potential employers so here are
some of the git commands we're going to
cover in this video which you will be
typing into your terminal or command
line on your computer
they are clone for example if there's a
repository that is not on your local
machine but it's on github
and you want to bring it down on your
local machine so you can use it locally
you use the clone command by the way all
of these commands are lowercase not
uppercase as we're gonna see as we go
through the examples in this video when
you have updated files or created or
deleted files and folders you're gonna
want to tell git that you made changes
and that you would like get to track
those changes so you use the add command
for that as I said earlier git is there
for you to save the changes you make in
your code so you do that through a
commit and we call it committing your
changes once you have made changes
locally on your computer and you are
ready to put them and get you tell get
to track them through the add command
you save your files to get through the
commit command and then you upload your
files to a place like github or another
what we call remote repository or github
alternative like bitbucket gitlab and
there's many of them you do this through
the push command when there are changes
to your code on github and you want to
bring those to your local machine then
you use the pull command you pull down
changes from the remote repository those
are all the commands that I want to
cover to get started again we're going
to go over examples of each of these the
first thing you will need to do is of
course sign up for an account on github
this is pretty straightforward you enter
minimal information and then you sign up
for an account you will get an email
that will ask you to verify and then you
can log into your account when you log
in you will either be on this page which
is your profile page that you can access
from this drop-down menu or you might be
on the dashboard page here either way
you will have access to this green
button here or this plus sign and the
drop down here where you can create a
new repository now a repository is
basically a project it's all of your
coding files and folders for whatever
kind of application that you are
building for example this is a
posit Ori that I have it's for a
curriculum app that I've been building
you can see the mock-ups pretty
straightforward application and in this
repository this is my complete project
with the folders and all of my coding
files are inside of these folders for
this one application each application or
project is in a separate repository so
I'm going to go ahead and create a new
repository here give it a name demo repo
by the way repo is just short for
repository I'm gonna leave these
settings as they are and click create
repository now you can create your files
and folders for this repository locally
on your machine or you can create them
straight in the online editor on the
github website so I'm gonna go ahead and
create a basic markdown file called a
readme and this is the most basic file
that you will find in almost every
project that contains text to describe
what the project is about what it does
and any other relevant information so
I'm gonna click here create a new file
I'm gonna name it readme dot MD for
markdown markdown is basically an easy
way to format your text in these sort of
files so I'm gonna come down here and
type some text now markdown has all
these shortcuts like one hash tag for a
main header so I'm just gonna put demo
here and then some plain text so I'll
put some description and then I'll
scroll to the bottom to commit the file
in other words save this file I just
want to point out really quickly that
this create readme MD is placeholder
text but if you don't write anything
else here when I commit this it will use
this text as the default so let me
commit and you can see here that this is
the commit message from when I saved
this readme file and now you can see the
readme file which because it's named
readme dot MD is the default file
that github always shows down here I can
also go into the file here which is the
same thing except with a few different
options here and an either screen I have
this edit this file option so I'm gonna
go ahead and do that I'm gonna simply
change this to an exclamation point now
the default text instead of create
readme MD is now update readme MD which
isn't that descriptive but it's okay for
right now so I'm gonna commit and by
committing I saved my changes here and
if I go to the demo repo it shows my
last commit message here as update
readme MD now if I want to see my entire
history of changes in other words every
commit that I've made I can come here to
commits and each commit has a unique
identifier and I can also see the
message or the title that I wrote on
these commits so I can come back to this
one and see what was added this green
with the plus signs means these lines
were added to this file and then I'll go
back and in the updated commit it shows
me this red with a minus sign
that means this line was deleted and
then the green with the plus means this
line was added anything that's white
means it stayed the same so this is a
very basic view of seeing changes now
what about using this on your local
machine if you are using a Mac or Linux
operating system you should already have
git installed you can check this by
opening your terminal or command line
application and typing in get space dash
dash version if git is not already
installed I highly recommend checking
out this tutorial by Atlassian which I
will link in the description below it
walks you through how to install git on
any operating system now I do want to
note for the Windows installation when
you download the get Windows installer I
recommend you choose the git bash option
from the install menu
you can of course use command prompt and
it will set up get in command prompt for
you but in the past I've had an easier
time with git bash on Windows for Mac it
gives you a few different options for
install but I highly recommend you use
the homebrew package manager if you can
and it takes you through all of the
steps here but again you probably
already have git installed if you're
using a Mac or Linux and don't need to
worry about this there's just one more
piece of setup before we continue with
the rest of the kit tutorial and that is
getting a code editor of course you can
write code in whatever you want any type
of word processing software will do from
notepad to Microsoft Word but there are
specific ones made for coding and many
of them are really good and free Visual
Studio code is a free code editor made
by Microsoft is widely used with people
learning to code and professionals alike
so you can install it for free from code
Visual Studio comm it's available on
every major operating system Mac Windows
and Linux now I have Visual Studio code
open with no files or folders inside if
you haven't used this before then all of
these icons on the side are how you're
going to navigate around your project
and use your tools so I'm gonna come to
this top one and this bar comes out
where I'm going to see all my files and
folders I'm just gonna open a folder
real quick in this test folder I'm gonna
go to my git then this is an empty
folder that i have i'm gonna click open
and now i have a folder that's open in
Visual Studio code that I can actually
add files and folders to but I'm not
going to right now because I'm actually
going to pull the repo that we created
at the beginning of this tutorial here
on github I'm gonna pull that to my
local system using git so in Visual
Studio code I have access to a terminal
from here that I'm going to use if I
come up to the top in the View menu I'm
going to come to terminal and
elected and now it opens this terminal
here by the way the only reason why this
says git is because my folder is named
git and because I've opened the folder
here it automatically uses that as the
directory for my terminal so now I want
to clone down my repo to my local
machine I want to pull all that code
down here so I can work with it locally
I'm gonna use a command called git clone
and then in clone or download here clone
with SSH exactly what we just set up so
I'm gonna copy this go back to my
terminal and paste and I'll hit enter
and now we can see a folder here which
is my repo from github that's pulled
down into the directory that I am in so
I'm going to move inside this folder
real quick from the command line which I
can just do by CD and then the name of
the folder to change directory into the
folder so now I am inside of the folder
demo repo which was the name of the
repository we created on github so when
it pulled it down it gave the folder
this name so my whole repository is
inside of that folder and now it says
get master now this might look different
on your machine this part looks
different on every machine I have a
specific setup to make it look like this
but either way you will probably see
some kind of indication that you are in
a git repository now now how do you know
this looks like a regular folder and a
regular readme file well there's
actually a hidden folder that you can't
see here and that you won't see on most
operating systems unless you have
selected to show hidden folders and that
is called the dot git directory so
there's just a special command in my
terminal that I will use to show you
that folder now the LA command that I
used here is actually a Mac shorthand
for LS space - la which means list
everything in the directory including
hidden files and folders so if you're
not on a Mac I don't think la will work
for you but you can use LS space - LA to
do the same
so you can see here's the readme file
and then there's something dot get and
because it's blue here that means it's
actually a folder and this hidden git
folder actually stores all of the files
that save your commits or your code
changes over time it has all of the
changes recorded in the history of this
repository which includes the ones we
made on github.com so now let's make
some more locally I'm gonna go into the
readme file and come here and add a sub
header not too creative I'm just gonna
call it sub header and then some more
text now that I have changed this file I
need to save the changes and git so I do
that through a commits till so first I'm
gonna use the git status command now the
git status command shows me all of the
files that were updated or created or
deleted but haven't been saved in a
commit yet so for example if I come here
and I create a new file I'm gonna call
this index dot HTML and I'm just going
to put a quick div inside with nothing
else and now let me rerun the git status
command and now you can see I have one
file that's been modified and one file
that it says is untracked meaning git
doesn't know about this file yet so you
have to tell get to track the file
before you can save it to get to do that
you need to use the git add command and
then tell it which files to track now
most of the time or a lot of the time
you see people use a period which means
you're telling it to track all of the
files that are listed here in both the
untracked and the modified section
so both the changes we made to readme
and the new file index.html would be
staged with git if we did get add period
because it includes all of the files you
could also optionally tell it just the
names of
each individual file or folder that you
want get to track in this case I'm just
going to use the dot now I'm going to
use git status again and now you can see
that all of the changes have been
tracked that's why they show up
differently now and they are ready to be
committed so I'm gonna come here and do
git commit dash M now dash M is for
message and you need to have a message
in order to commit your files the
message could be one character and
meaningless if you want but there needs
to be a message and ideally that message
should have something to do with the
what and why behind the commit you're
making so I'm gonna add a message here
added index.html and this is just the
title of the message if you remember
from the web interface there were two
boxes a title and a description this
first - M and what's inside of the
quotes is a message you can add a second
one for the description box so I can say
some description and I'll click enter
and now it gives me some information -
files change 5 insertions but we've
still only saved our code locally the
commit isn't live on github yet we make
it live by using another git command
called git push which means I want to
push this live to a remote repository
where my project is hosted
in order to push them to github under
your account you're going to have to
prove to github that you are the owner
of your account so you have to connect
your local machine to your github
account somehow the way this is done is
by using SSH keys you need to start by
generating a key locally using the SSH
key gene command then you specify the
type of encryption and then the strength
of encryption and at the end you need to
include your github email address this
is just a test for me because I already
have key setup so I'm just going to put
a fake email address but make sure that
the email address you enter here is the
same one you use to log in to your
github account click enter now the
default file for the SSH key is inside
your user directory in the dot SSH
directory and it will be called ID
underscore RSA I'm going to give it a
different name here because I already
have a key under that name you can
optionally enter a passphrase for your
key here or leave it blank so I'm just
gonna click enter to leave it blank and
my key has been generated now I am going
to search for the key that I just
generated and now I find that there are
two so there's test key and test keep up
so test key dot pub is the key that you
are going to upload to your github
interface pub stands for public it's
called your public key which means that
it's okay for other people to see this
key the key that was generated without
the dot pub extension is called your
private key and is the one that you have
to keep secure on your local machine you
don't share this key with anybody how it
works is that the public key you put on
github and then every time you want to
connect to github or push your code on
github or use your account via your
local machine you use your private key
to show github that you are the one that
generated this public key it's a
mathematical proof that only this
private key could have generated this
Blackey I'm going to print out this
public key and your key should look
something like this
SSH - RSA it starts with this it has a
bunch of characters in the middle and it
ends with your email now you need to
copy this whole key which you can do by
highlighting it in your terminal or
command line which automatically copies
it you don't need to do ctrl or command
C because ctrl C actually means
something completely different in the
terminal not copy there's also a
terminal command that allows you to copy
it's called PB copy and then you do the
less than symbol and then the path to
your file so it's in our user home
directory and I didn't actually push it
put it in the dot SSH directory but this
is the directory you would have your key
in and then it's just test key dot Pub
and now it's copied to my clipboard on
github I'm gonna go to settings and in
the list of all settings I'm gonna go to
SSH and GPG keys and you can see any SSH
keys associated with your account then
you just click on new SSH key you can
give it whatever title you want this is
just for your reference and then you
paste your key in here and I'm gonna
remove the extra enter at the end and
now add SSH key to confirm my password
and now you can see my key was
successfully added the only thing left
to do is to make sure that your local
get command line interface knows about
the key you just generated and I'm going
to link all of these steps in the
description below you need to start the
SSH agent then if you're using version
10.12 0.2 or later you will need to
modify this file your SSH config and add
this text to it I'm going to just show
you how to get into that file now paste
the location of the file in your SSH
directory and then anywhere in this file
perhaps at the end you can paste in that
information I'm not going to do that
because I already have my file
set up so I'm going to delete it after
you do that you'll run this SSH ad
command from your terminal and then your
key will be set up to work with git
again all of the information that I
covered with keys here is going to be
linked in the description below but this
is the general way that you will do it
with any operating system although there
might be some slight variations
now there are two more arguments we have
to put here the first one is origin and
the second one is master now origin is
an option set for us here and is
basically a word that stands for the
location of our git repository master is
the branch that we want to push to and
we'll get into what that means in a
minute I'm going to click enter and now
I'll refresh this page and you can see
my code changes are all live on github
now you can also see that there are
three commits to that we made online on
github.com and one that we made locally
and pushed up to github comm of course
this was our commit message that we made
locally and this was the description
that we wrote after that second dash M
we can see all of our file changes that
we made locally here as well so this was
to demonstrate how to create a new git
repository using github but what about
if you start a repo locally so let me
exit out of these and I will create a
new folder here called
demo repo to drag it outside so now it's
in a completely separate folder from the
other git repository that we have but
this one's not a git repository yet and
nothing's in there so I'm going to move
into that folder in the terminal demo
too so now I'm in demo 2 you can see
it's not a git repository even if I look
for that hidden git folder it's not
there so let me first add a file in here
and I'm again going to add a readme file
dot MD and I'm going to add a header
demo to and some text now if I want to
turn this into a git repository I can
use the command line and say git init
and it says initialize git repository in
yada-yada this folder and now you can
see I have the get keyword there and if
I do get staff
I can see there's this untracked readme
file I will go ahead and add that file
either with the period or the name of
the file get status again okay so the
file is ready to be committed and now I
will do git commit dash M created readme
and now I'll put description here and
enter now what if I want to push this
live
let's try get push origin master and now
you can see it's giving me this error
fatal origin does not appear to be a git
repository because we didn't clone this
down from a git repository we didn't
already create this repo on github we
created it locally so get is saying I
have no idea where to push this to
because it's not connected to anything
so we have to create that connection and
first the easiest way to do this is by
creating an empty git repository up on
github so I'm gonna come here create new
repository I'm gonna call this demo repo
to don't need a description going to
leave all this here now I have another
empty repository so to start pushing
here I'm going to copy this and say git
remote now remote means somewhere else
but not on this computer we're gonna use
this to add a reference to the remote
repository on github and then I'm gonna
say add origin and paste that link that
I copied and I can check that by saying
git remote - V and it shows any remote
repositories that I've connected to this
repo now that these are set up I can now
use git push origin master just as I did
before now there's a shortcut here
because if I don't want to type out this
whole thing every time in the future I
can just use git push but I have to set
something called an upstream meaning
this is where I want to push it to by
default so I'm going to
- you purse at upstream and then enter
and in the future I can just use get
push without typing out origin/master
it says - github looks like everything
was pushed just fine I will refresh this
page and I can see the readme that I
just added so that's how you initialize
a repository locally and push it to a
remote location like github so let's
review the workflows that we've gone
over so far and compare the flow of
adding code in the github interface
versus writing it locally so when we
first started working in the github
interface we wrote some code in the
readme and then we committed our changes
we saved them to get now notice there
wasn't an added step here we never did a
get add to stage changes
well that's because github handles that
for us so really by committing and
github we are adding and committing at
the same time and then that was it
really
because it was our repository we had
full access to change whatever we wanted
we could just update the code just by
committing it in the github interface of
course we didn't have to push the code
because it was already live on github
there's no other remote repository
because it's already in the remote
repository now if we didn't own the
repository or we didn't have access
rights or we needed other people to
review our code before we merged it in
with all the rest of the code then we
would also have to take the extra step
of making a pull request which is
something we're going to cover later in
this video so let's compare this
workflow if we're just writing code on
github versus doing it locally and then
pushing it up to github so locally in
our text editor we wrote the code and
then we had to do get add to let get
know about the changes and then we save
them to get using the git commit command
and then we push them to the remote
repository on github using the git push
command and that update
github is code or the code in the github
repository with our changes that were
made locally and then just like before
if we didn't have access rights or we
needed a code review before we merge
changes in we'll need to make a pull
request so these two methods cover the
most basic ways to use git by using the
github web interface and then doing it
locally if you have any questions about
this then please leave them in the
comments below otherwise let's move on
to get branching
let's first go over some of the concepts
of branching and then we'll dive into a
practical example now what is get
branching you've seen in our examples
that were on something called the master
branch now master is a naming convention
for the main or the default branch in a
repository so if you are just working
off of one branch that's where your code
will live and all your code all your
commits everything will be in that one
branch now this is called branching
because it starts to look more like a
tree when you have multiple branches so
we saw earlier that we had a master
branch we were committing to that master
branch but we could also make another
branch we'll call it feature branch so
let's talk about what happens when we
create a new branch at first the code on
master and this new feature branch will
be exactly the same but as you make
updates to the feature branch those
changes are only seen in the feature
branch so if you make changes on the
feature branch you make a commit to save
those changes onto that branch and then
you switch back to the master branch you
won't be able to see any of the changes
that you made on that feature branch
each individual branch has no way of
knowing what commits or what changes
have been made to any other branch each
branch is only keeping track of what
changes are made on its own branch now
you can continue to change the code on
master branch and save it through a
commit to the master branch and then if
you switch back to the feature branch
likewise you will not be able to see the
changes that you just saved to master
why is this useful it's extremely useful
because you will be building out new
features to applications that may break
your code or they are not finished yet
and you don't want to save them to the
main master branch you want to work on
them in kind of a sandbox area so you
can
all the code you need and get it correct
and in the state that you want before
you merge it back into the main branch
of the code base and this is really
helpful when you have many different
people working in the same repository or
a lot of different branches going on at
once one very common thing that you'll
see in development is that you'll be
working on let's say this feature branch
for a week or more and you have all of
these changes that you've made and then
you find out there's this major bug that
you have to fix real quick so for that
we make this other branch called it a
hotfix branch here represented by yellow
and you can see that I made the change
in one commit to fix whatever bug was
wrong with the code on its own branch I
made sure it was working correctly and
then I merged it back into the master
branch now that we've gone over the
concepts of branching let's dive into
the command line and try it out and now
I'm using a full-screen terminal just so
I have more space as I'm running
different git commands that are gonna
take up more screen space to show you
but it works the exact same way as the
terminal inside of vs code so I'm back
in my terminal inside of my demo repo
again and you can see here I have
information about my git branch again
you might see this presented in
different ways it shows you're on the
master branch if I type in get branch
you can see that I currently only have
one branch and it's master and you can
also see there's a star beside it and
that means that I am currently on that
branch so I'm going to hit the letter Q
here to get out of that and now I'm
going to create a new branch so I do
that with git checkout and get check out
is what you will use to switch between
branches but to tell it to create a new
branch use dash B and then you give it
the name of your branch so in this case
I'm going to call it feature now if
you're working
in a real application with people you
want to make this name as descriptive as
possible some people like to use feature
slash the ticket number or description
or you can use - and then you could give
it the issue number like if it's a
github issue number 11 or whatever your
convention you want to use and then you
can make this longer if you want and put
some more details i'm going to call this
feature
- readme instructions because i'm just
going to be updating a section of the
readme click enter and now it says i
switched to a new branch meeting i
created this new branch called feature
read the instructions and now you see
that my branch changed so now if I do
get branch again I have two branches
listed here and the top one is starred
and highlighted so it shows me which
branch I'm currently on I'm gonna hit
cue and like I mentioned get checkout
will switch between branches so now that
I am on this feature reading the
instructions I can check out master and
now you see I switched to master I'll do
git branch shows them on master now and
I will do another get check out feature
readme instructions you see that I hit
the tab button and it auto filled the
rest of the branch so I didn't have to
type out the whole long name you can
also hit tab even if you don't start at
the beginning like in this case I
started typing feature and then hit tab
but I could actually start typing
instructions and hit tab and it still
autocompletes
now this is very useful because
eventually when you work in a repo
you're gonna start a lot of stuff with
feature or with bug or hotfix or
whatever so only your last few words
will be unique so that's just something
useful to know so now I'm back on the
feature readme instructions branch and
I'm gonna make some changes on this
branch so I'm in my code here I'm gonna
come into my readme and make a new
section
I'm gonna say just local development or
something and then give it one step I'm
gonna say open index.html in your
browser just as a demo alright I saved
that and you can see in vs code it gives
me this M here meaning it's been
modified since I've last checked this in
to get that's kind of a nice feature to
have to see which files you've added in
which files you've modified right in
your text editor alright now that I've
modified some files here I'm gonna do
the git status command again and it says
I modified readme so first I'm going to
save things that I've changed on this
branch so I'm going to do the git add
command and I'm just gonna stage the
readme changes and now I will do a git
commit dash M and say oops I have to put
that quote so updated readme okay so you
can see I have one file changed for
insertions so now it's saved to get but
it's only saved on this feature reading
the instructions branch so if I do a git
checkout master come back to my code and
you can see the changes aren't here
because they're only on that other
branch now if I want to here I can go
ahead and merge these two branches
locally using the git merge command but
before I do that I just want to double
check and see the code that emerging in
which I can do through the git diff
command now diff or diffing shows me
what changes have been made it compares
two versions of the code and shows me
all of the lines that have been changed
and you kind of saw this in the get
interface because you saw a nice visual
representation of the diff where it
showed in green with a plus sign the
lines that had been added and then in
red with the minus sign the lines that
had been removed and let me say git diff
and the name of the branch hit enter
and now you can see it shows which file
it's talking about this readme MD file
and in white it shows text that was
already been there that hasn't been
changed and then it shows that my master
branch doesn't have some of the changes
that are in my other branch so I'm gonna
hit Q here to get out of this all right
now I could go ahead and like I said use
the git merge command pass in the branch
and it'll merge in those changes but the
more common pattern that you are going
to see is pushing these changes on that
branch up to github and then making a PR
so I'm going to change back to the
feature branch and now I'll do git
status and it says I have no changes to
commit because they've already been
committed but I do need to push them up
to github so let me run git push and now
you can see since I'm on a new branch it
says that I need to tell it which branch
on github I want to push to now the
answer is almost always that the branch
will be named the same thing on github
and on your local machine so I could
copy this line and now you'll notice
this set upstream flag here
is the same thing that we were doing
before with the - you it's just
shorthand for set upstream so I'm gonna
hit enter here and now it's pushed up to
github and it's even giving me a hint
for how to create a pull request on
github by giving me these instructions
here so what is a pull request or a PR
it's basically a request to have your
code pulled into another branch in the
example we're using today we have a
feature branch and we want to have our
code pulled into the master branch so we
make a PR from the feature branch to the
master branch now once we have made a PR
anyone can review our code comment on it
ask us to make changes or updates now
after you make a PR you can also update
the code just by making additional
commits and pushing them up to github as
long as it's on the same branch that
you're making the PR with once the PR is
merged you'll generally delete your
feature or source branch and to switch
back to the master branch then when you
want to make additional coding changes
you will create another new branch and
start the process over make your commits
make a PR and then merge again and I
could go too straight to this URL but
I'm going to show you how to do it
manually on github first so I look at my
github interface and you can see already
github picked up on the fact that I just
pushed a new branch so now it's asking
me right here if I want to compare this
new branch to another branch and create
a pull request and it takes me to this
screen here now sometimes this is
confusing for people which branch is
being merged into which branch this
github interface does a pretty good job
because of the arrow so you can see that
the branch you're comparing this feature
readme instructions will be merged into
the base so there's always a base branch
where all the code is going to get
merged into and then there's
branch you're comparing so now I have
this message I have a title that says I
updated readme and I can put some more
description here so usually I'm gonna
put a list of the changes that I've made
and maybe some description as to why I
made certain decisions so here I'm just
gonna say added section about local
development to the readme and I will
create a pull request now that I've
created a pull request I can actually
come here in the interface I can see any
comments that people have made on the
pull request or I can write more
comments of my own I can look through
all the commits I've made that I'm
trying to merge into master right now
and I can also look at all the files
that have been changed and see the diff
of what's been added removed or updated
another thing I can do right here is if
I want to make a comment about a
particular line of code that I've
written I can press the plus button this
blue plus button and now I can make a
comment there I'm just gonna say add a
new sub header and add it as a single
comment and you can see that the comment
appears at the line of code where you
hit the plus button this is a really
nice way if there are multiple people
working on a repository to make comments
about specific lines of code and then
usually the person who created this PR
will reply to them with an explanation
or make another commit if changes need
to be made to the code or something
alright so I'm going to go ahead and
merge this PR and you'll notice that I
added the single comment it says resolve
now because I'm the owner here I have
full permissions I don't have to resolve
I can still merge the PR if you don't
have permissions or your repo set up in
a certain way then you might have to
resolve comments before you can merge
anyway I'm just going to merge here
confirm and merge successful
now that the PR is merged I'm going to
go over to the code and if I scroll down
you can see that I am on the master
branch and my changes are also here so
the branch was successfully merged so
locally now I'm going to switch to the
master branch and if you look at the
code the changes aren't there yet and
that's because they are only on github
and I need to pull them down to my local
environment so to get the changes on my
local master branch from origin I'm
going to do git pull now if I didn't
already set the upstream I would have to
do git pull origin master but I already
have an upstream set here so I'm just
gonna do git pull and then enter and you
can see one file changed for insertions
and now if I look at my code I can see
my local master has also been updated
with the changes from the branch and now
that I am done with that feature branch
I'm going to do git branch and it's
still there even though I'm not going to
be using it again because you don't
really reuse branches that you've
already merged into your master branch
so I'm gonna go ahead and delete this
branch so I'm gonna do git branch dash D
and then the name of the branch and
again I can tab over so I'll hit enter
and now it says I deleted that branch so
now if I do get branch and I only have
master again all right
well that's all fine and great and works
well but in real life you're not always
going to have such an easy time merging
there's something called merge conflicts
and get where basically you're building
your own code writing a bunch of code on
your own branch maybe other people are
writing code on their branches and
master is getting updated from multiple
different places so it's possible for
multiple people to change the same files
and so sometimes git doesn't know which
code you want to keep or which code is
redundant or which code do you want to
get rid of so you'll have to manually do
that let's try that out let me create
another branch I'm gonna do get check
out dash B and then I'm just gonna call
this quick test all right I'm on the
quick test branch now I'm gonna come
into index.html and I'm going to add a P
tag here then say world and P alright so
I modified this file let me go ahead and
do get status it's always a good idea to
do get status before you commit anything
looks good what I can also do from here
is do a git diff enter and it shows me
all of the changes that I've made since
my last commit so I'm gonna hit Q and
now I will commit these now generally
the workflows been get add and then file
name or a period to add everything in
this directory this time there's a
shortcut because we've just modified one
file and the file has already been
committed to get in the past which is
why it says modified or not created so
what I'm gonna do is get commit and then
instead of - M I'm gonna do - a which
stands for add and M at the same time
for message then I'm going to put my
commit message so this basically adds
and commits at the same time but it only
works for modified files not for newly
created files because if it's newly
created you have to stage that with git
and let get know about it first for my
message I'll just say added world okay
and now I have one file changed to
insertions now let me go to my master
branch to get checkout master you can
see I don't have the changes from my
other branch there but what if I updated
the same line so on master now I'm
updating line two and here I'm gonna put
there so hello there
so now master has aligned to you but the
new branch I created
also has a line too now everything is
fine now because both branches are
separate but what if I try to merge
these two together whose line two is
going to be put there so let's try that
I'm going to go to my quick test branch
so I'm gonna do get check out quick test
and now it's actually giving me an error
and not letting me change branches
because I have local changes that line
two that I added in master it says it's
going to be overwritten if I change
branches so it's asking me to commit
before I change so that way that line
two will be saved to get in the master
branch and won't be lost when I change
branches now stashing is a little bit
beyond the scope of this tutorial but
it's basically a way for you to stash
your changes somewhere and then you can
retrieve them later but it's not making
a commit to get it's like a temporary
holding place so we're not gonna do that
I'm just gonna go ahead and commit so
let me do get status first all right and
I'm gonna use the shorthand because I
only have the modified file there so I'm
gonna do git commit dash a.m. and then a
commit message I'm gonna say added there
and now I should be able to check out
and press the up arrow key I should be
able to check out this quick test branch
and before I merge master into this
branch I'm gonna diff against master
real quick and it shows me the changes
here so now I am going to do merge
master so remember how I said before
that merging locally wasn't the regular
pattern
well it isn't for merging branches into
master but master gets updated as you go
along as you're working on your project
because maybe other people are merging
into master and you don't have those
changes in your branch but you don't
want to get too far behind master as
you're working because then it's going
to be really difficult to merge
later so as changes are made to master
in the github repo you're going to want
to pull those down to your local master
branch and then whatever feature branch
you're working off of like quick test
here you'll want to use git merge master
to keep your branch up to date with
what's going on in master so that's what
we're doing here get merge master hit
enter and now it says we have a conflict
so we have a merge conflict in
index.html so there are a couple ways to
fix merge conflicts interfaces like
github give you an interface to fix them
you can also fix it in the terminal but
the easiest way to fix merge conflicts
is directly in your code a nice code
editor like vs code will let you click
buttons like accept the current change
or accept incoming or take both of these
but you can also come in here make the
changes that you want and delete these
lines that get added this lets get know
that there's a conflict and first
between this head and these equal signs
it shows the code that we have on the
current branch that we are on and then
it shows the code coming from the other
branch that we're trying to merge in so
in this case I am just going to delete
these lines and save both of the changes
but in this case one two line two and
one two line three and this is just
letting it know what we want to do
because it didn't know how to handle the
conflict now we have handled it and
deleted the conflict markers we can now
look here and see that we need to make
another commit even though it seems like
we are adding and subtracting the same
things we basically need to make a
commit because we have fixed the merge
conflicts so I'm gonna say here get
commit - am and I can say merged in
master or updated with master or
something like that
and now I've officially updated my
branch with the changes that have been
happening on master branch and I can
continue coding whatever feature bug-fix
or whatever I'm doing on this quick test
branch
so what if we make a mistake what if we
accidentally add something or commit
something to get and we didn't mean to
do it we can actually undo our stages or
our commits so let me come to read me
I'm gonna add another line here and say
have fun okay so I've made a change here
on line 12 and back in my demo repo I'm
gonna do get status so now let's say I
want to get add this readme and let me
do get status again and you can see
before is that change is not staged and
now changes to be committed meaning
they've been staged already but what if
I want to undo staging what if I didn't
mean to staged this file I can actually
easily undo it by using the git reset
command so I can either do get reset
with no arguments or I can say get reset
and just the name of the file that I
want to understate so here I'm just
gonna do the plane get reset and it
gives me a list of the files so
unstained is after reset readme now if I
do another git status it shows me that
this file is no longer staged so what if
I want to undo a commit so let me go
ahead and add the readme file and then
I'm gonna come and commit readme and I'm
gonna say added install step now if I do
get status you'll see there's nothing to
commit because all changes have now been
committed well if I made a mistake on
that commit I can use that same get
reset command and this time I'm going to
say get reset head in all caps and what
head means to get is a pointer to the
last commit so I'm telling it to do
something with the last commit and then
I'm gonna say tilde one which is telling
it instead of pointing to this last
commit that I just made right here I
want you to go back one commit further
and head will now point back one commit
further meaning it will
completely undo the commit that I just
made let me click enter and now you can
see it says I unstaged the changes so
I'm gonna say get status and what
happened was that it unstaged and
uncommitted those last changes so if I
do get diff you'll see that get picks
this up as a new change now
now if you have many different commits
you might want to go back to a specific
commit or undo multiple commits and for
that there's no quick pointer and get
like the upper case head pointer where
you can just look at the last commit or
use that to undo the last commit but you
can see a log of all your commits and
you'll see that these are arranged in
reverse chronological order so this is
the latest commit that we made and you
can see with the commit message it's
also why it's important to write a good
commit message because it's easier for
humans to scroll through and see which
commit is which to get these commits are
differentiated with this unique hash
here so if you want to go back to a
certain commit you can copy one of these
hashes let's say I want to go back to
added world before I added the there
line so I want to basically undo when I
merge this there from master into this
branch so let me copy this commit hash
and by the way when you see all of these
commits you can scroll down with
spacebar and now it shows this is the
end so I'll say quit so I'm gonna do git
reset and then the hash of that commit
and it's unstaged any changes made to
these files after this commit so you can
see the changes are still there I added
have fun and this line three in the
index.html but they are just not saved
in git or stage with get any longer so
what if I was just testing something out
and I want to get rid of all of the
changes after a certain point well I can
do that by using the
reset command as well let me just grab a
commit hash so I'm gonna go back just a
couple of random commits to this commit
right here where I said updated readme
gonna hit Q and now I'm gonna do get a
reset - - hard meaning I want all of the
changes to not just be unstaged but to
be completely removed so head is now
pointing to a different commit because
I've undone several commits now and if I
look at my files
we've just completely gone back in time
and erased the latest updates so those
are the basics of branching merging
fixing merge conflicts and undoing
staging and commits that you've made one
more thing that I want to quickly
mention is forking you may have seen
this already in the git interface you
can hit fork here and then it's going to
make a complete copy of the repository
now why would you want to fork well you
probably don't want to fork your own
repo because you already have full
access to all of the code here but you
don't for other people's repos so let me
find just a random repo on github
okay so here's V ojs so let me click on
this and I actually don't have access to
change anything in this repo so if I
want to make a PR against this repo and
request for my changes to be added or if
I just want to be able to branch off of
the code in this repo and do whatever I
want with it
then I want to fork it so I'm going to
hit the fork button here
and fork it to my user account these are
just groups that I'm a part of on github
sometimes it takes a minute to fork over
all the code especially with view J s
because it's a large repository alright
and now you can see the repo is no
longer under the view J s organization
now it's under my personal github and
now that I've fought this I have
complete control to make any updates or
changes that I want to this code so if I
want to come in to readme and hit the
pencil update this I can say hi there
and now I can come to the bottom and
commit changes again so I can say
updated read me or whatever I want I'm
just gonna leave it with the default
text again commit to the dev branch
so before we worked off the master
branch as being the default branch but
sometimes when you're working in a
larger project with other people you are
going to want to create multiple
branches like master staging and dev for
different kinds of environments so in
this case dev is set to the default
branch for this repository instead of
master so I'm just gonna commit my
changes directly to dev and you can see
my changes here of course they aren't
part of the main view J s view
repository but they're part of the one
that I forked because I forked a
complete copy of that repository
including the branches associated with
it and you can see dev is marked as the
default so now what if I wanted to get
my changes back into this VJ s
repository of course I don't but what if
I did I would go and create a pull
request so new pull request and then as
my base the place that I want to merge
my changes into I would put the
repository that I forked from this VJ s
repository and the branch and I want to
compare that with my repository that I
forked and
the branch on my repository that I
updated of course I'm not going to click
create pull request because this is just
a demo I can also see the diff town here
of the changes that I've made and what
commits I've made to this branch on my
fork now if I want to merge within my
fork I can do that easily let's say of
course there isn't anything to compare
because I'm comparing the same branch
here but I could merge into any other
branch
let me find master here so I could merge
straight into master and you can see I
can create pull request now I created a
pull request
and I'm gonna create pull requests and
you can see they had a bunch of default
text added to the for request
information but I'm just going to go
ahead and merge go back to the code if I
scroll down of course I'm on dev it says
hi there and now if I go to master it
also has my changes on master because I
merged them generally speaking after we
merge a branch into one of our default
branches like master then we would clean
up the branch that has just been merged
in other words we would delete it from
github and from our local machine
because we're not using that branch
anymore but it's a little bit different
when we use branches like dev staging
and master because generally you're
merging your feature branches into
either dev or master and you have dev
and master and sometimes staging
reserved for just merging into so you
don't make any changes on dev and master
themselves you'll just be merging other
branches into dev or master depending on
how your code base is set up in a large
project like Vijay s we would merge all
of our feature branches or bug fixes or
whatever into the dev branch and then
delete the branch that we just merged in
and then when all the changes on the dev
branch are ready those get merged into
master but dev never gets deleted just
like master never gets deleted those
kind of stay around forever all the
other branches are just temporary so me
having my own Fork allows me full reign
full access full control of crud
operations create read update delete
whatever I want to do with all of this
code all of these files and if I want to
make some major updates what I'm gonna
do is fork the repository which I
already did pull my fork down to my
local machine make all the updates that
I want to test them out whatever I want
to do I'll push them back up to my fork
and then I will create a PR against the
original repository they
much for watching I hope that you
enjoyed this video and that you also got
something out of it if you did then
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to the free code Kent Channel
don't forget to check out my youtube
channel called Faraday Academy where I
do weekly videos and livestreams on
Python and JavaScript and other related
programming topics I would also
appreciate if you would leave me a
comment here and let me know what you
liked about the video or any other
feedback that you might have have a
great day and I hope you enjoy using it